our company now has 900 of these pens
please use uploaded logo wow that's an
amazing ways just like you watching this
video welcome everyone to Mile
infuriating this is make you Molly
infuriated I have a confession to make
first of all when I looked up at this
subreddit this image shows up the way my
grandmother eats pizza
I've eaten pizza this way for over 20
years and every time we are out with
French and I start eating my pizza it
always goes weird and quiet and I'm like
what and everyone's just staring to what
I'm doing to the pizza
it's amazing what you eat pizza with
your hands creams bro listen there's a
stigma all I ask is that you try it ok
it's really epic I don't like the crust
and when you're done eating it you have
a pizza frame and you can put your face
in it and be like hey pizza face it
salsa I'll cut you with you try it and
then you can see if you like it alright
let's move on to more mildly infuriating
shin Buster 9000 I'm not sure what I'm
looking at it's not a bed frame that
sticks out I think that site is supposed
to go towards the wall you're you
literally that you're using your bed
backwards that is making me more
infuriated hits then the post itself job
expectations minimum 5 years experience
in motion design graphic design
animation or familiar seniority level
entry it's like the meme you need
experience to get job but I need job to
get experience
society seems fair YouTube they
monetizes tons of videos with no reason
whatsoever
also YouTube lies ecology I got this is
YouTube summarize this video showed up
in my recommendation it has like 80
million views because it has lice Aiko
she naked it'd be funny you could use
that thumbnail and see if you get the
monetize yeah I'm gay I feel like I'm
getting mildly but I'm getting mildly to
monetize I mean fury ate it
happening written questions number two
political efficacy is described as what
your vote counts answer incorrect answer
you are vote counts my disappointment
isn't measurable and my Friday is ruined
one two three four five seven that's it
that is mylène for your reading I don't
know it's a I feel like mildly
infuriating is worse than just
infuriating because if you really gotta
amp yourself up to get really infuriated
about something mildly infuriating it's
like someone poking you with a stick and
I hear you annoyed are you annoyed yet
that's what it that's like that's like
when you try and enjoy your pizza and
you start eating it and everyone judges
you for the way you eat your pizza
that's mildly infuriating okay let me
eat my goddamn pizza there I like my
goddamn pizza incorrect nineteen forty
five point five correct nineteen forty
eight point fifty did I say it wrong
that would be mildly infuriating if I
said it wrong people who do this are
just the worst sell chicken what do you
mean people there aren't vegans shut up
vegans okay no I I get it
I do this all the time I wouldn't do it
with a frozen food that's come on they
have people there they gotta do
something I'm joking of course
I only do it if I'm really in a hurry
okay I actually I don't even do it that
anymore I don't do it anymore
my new insurance refuses to pay for meds
I've been on for years my doc gets free
samples and gives them to me this is the
packaging for 15 days of pills
what there's so many layers of
infuriating here the waste of packaging
get a tune by be like ah what I can see
the carbon I work with an office full of
sadists oh the effort that this would
have taken as well that's beautiful
maybe they try to do like a creeper face
and then it didn't work out at least
then I would be a well valid
justification these baseball fields in
my city ah
this makes me angry what is it about
symmetry that is so beautiful and what
is it about asymmetry that is so
infuriating what makes it so annoying
it's like I want to be God and just be
like you know I'm saying make part
noises while I just
as well God that pisses me off I'm not
gonna lie too I'm actually quite pissy
peace please do not park like this this
is my car on the right I was
contemplating having to crawl across the
passenger seat when the woman who owned
the car on the Left came back I pointed
out calmly that she needs to be more
aware of the cars around her when
parking you were on the side of the how
do these people exist it blows my mind
she even tweeted it out peace is Christ
there's so many delusional people oh my
god it's like the other day I drove my
sit to the airport and there was these
two two trucks literally next to each
other taking up both the in spaces we're
on a rush to go to the airport and this
is like a British road that changes
frequently it's not like there's this
one road that they've been sitting on
for a long time there's no reason for
him to try and pass his truck that is
clearly driving the same speed as you
are and then when I passed him I
obviously have to tell him you're an
idiot so I hug ppppp you're an idiot
and then he hung back at me and I hope
you're watching because you're a stinky
brainer don't ever hug back to me again
you're a fool
a stinky fool and I was mildly
infuriating the way my dad puts things
away in the fridge this is a piece of
steak mmm delicious steak for later look
I'll have that later thank you a plate
wrapping foil no waste of environment
straight to the fridge with you you know
what is this someone in my office keeps
pouring their coffee grounds the toilet
and leaving it like this that is very
important is more than mild maybe got on
the rim of the seat dude I don't want a
coffee but no one wants coffee but no
one I say it now I there's a stigma
against coffee butts my school that
started an eco-friendly project by
giving out apples to students okay I'm
already annoyed did you do this on
purpose whatever is wrong with you this
feels like Japan in Japan they have
super strict recycling rules let me see
if I can find it so naturally when me
and my sister try and recycle for the
first time we were terrified you have to
separate everything and if you mess up
you get the
red level of shame saying you did it
wrong and they won't accept your trash
and you're like oh that's that's
actually really good like everyone has
to recycle that's good for the
environment that everyone makes an
effort to recycle but my god they wrap
everything in plastic literally
everything is wrapped in plastic you buy
candy and like every single piece of
candy is wrapped in plastic you buy
plastic and that's wrapped in plastic
what they need to do alright here's my
here's my pitch to save the environment
every single product has a designated
carton right a recyclable carton that
uses minimal amount of wasteful
materials if not hundred percent and
everything goes in a specific place so
they can all be used again at some point
right does that make sense
am i making sense here it would be
easier to recycle there would be no ways
PewDiePie for president thank you and if
you don't recycle you get thrown in
prison and death possible death
PewDiePie for president thank you see
I'm getting I'm getting worked up I
think that's why I'm so aggressive today
again what is wrong drop my remote was
looking for the battery for new power
that is the worst I can relate to this
so hard when you drop something on the
floor you hear the sound you don't look
properly I'm like yeah I can hear what
that landed I can hear what that Lander
than that where that took off three
hours later you still haven't found it
oh my god this is literally Mars yeah I
claim eyes this computer without telling
her because it just hurts me so much cuz
my state does pottery so she has so much
clay oh my god she borrowed my tripod
once it used to be black but now it's
white hello
blip blop I just want to ask a question
why are you using my name as your
account name because it's my name this
is some genius doesn't know that people
with the exact same name exist
you win posture why have you taken my
name there can only be one Felix
Kjellberg there's a website how many of
me well you can look up how many other
people have your name that doesn't want
to work right now so I want you to do it
but try it out 20 to genius tech hacks
to make you say wow
that is a genius Hank Hank I love
listening to speak it to your ear these
channels thank you
five minutes craft is like one of the
biggest channels on YouTube it's like
the perfect clickbait because the
thumbnail is like asking a question
right but it's an impossible thing like
Oh what happens if I pour Nutella
something happens if I pour it in and
watermelon oh I can cook egg on like
what is it
Oh what happens if I pour coke and
strawberries in ice cubes packets like
no I don't actually care about this but
it has bright colors and it's well put I
need to learn from this I'm actually
just jealous pissed me off clearly me
getting like what 13 billion views it's
not enough I'm jealous when you come
across people like this who have no
respect for others time hi there I am at
Starbucks sorry I won't be able to make
it today a little notice would have been
nice okay so they try to sell their
their phone that's funny
Jesus Christ my god yes preach it preach
it it's like when you tried to sell some
[ __ ] on eBay
it blows my mind you're like selling
something that's worth like a hundred
bucks but you're like I just want to get
rid of it so I sell it for thirty and
then they're like twenty bucks okay I'm
like no shut the [ __ ] up that's the
price Jesus Christ
what about 25 shut up you're wasting my
time
hi sis items still available it's on the
site isn't it I don't even need this
money I just don't want to waste it and
throw it away I'm practically giving it
away okay so why don't you give it for
free then shut up shut up I'm so angry I
need to hit something whoever invented
cables needs to die I hate cables my
house to me is a freaking psychopath
that's kind of aesthetically pleasing at
least it's symmetric apparently I was
taking too long to finish a puzzle
so my housemate finished it and then did
the biggest power move oh that's funny
I like that well I played gamer not one
not two not three
[Laughter]
oh that's beautiful that's a power mode
that's the true power mode you know this
is America this lunch table clearly
someone just assembled it wrong it's not
that annoying
what is this expert towing your bike oh
god I can't watch this
no no stop God that pissed me out I'm
truly mad truly sickening took me eight
years plus a hangover to finally notice
what oh my god
yeah we have this in our bathroom one of
the tiles it's the wrong way it's super
annoying
that's not too bad though you think
you're eight years to notice that then
you don't deserve to get annoyed by it I
revoke your annoyance privileges it take
a certain kind of man to get annoyed
properly okay it takes a certain kind of
man to understand how incompetent the
world is because I am extra big large
brain this I would have notice that in
two seconds especially since you zoomed
in on it it made it easier to spot my
school just removed the urinal divider
why another great thing about Japan I
don't mind showing my peepee let it be
no but I also appreciate a little bit of
space when I make a pee-pee that's all
I'm gonna say about that why are the
clone guard sir would you remove that
not my pick but damn it pisses me off
yeah what do you what do you expect
this is the quality of life that people
do people go through their whole years
of school years of training to then not
care about what you do and this is the
result I care about quality in my videos
this would never happen to me oh my god
can be wrapped inside a cake seriously
I'm stuck in the middle and you want my
leg rub tell them to remove his leg it's
not that hard
hey excuse me would you mind moving away
from my seat it's always like this they
take a photo and post it online Vedas
Jesus Christ don't complain that pisses
me off more to be
honest but you've decided to just take a
photo of it instead of just telling
someone if it's annoying how is the
world going to improve if you don't tell
people that they're idiots promise me if
Sean's being a ding dong tell them and
not online tell them let's get real they
probably want to know when you have no
notifications and this number just won't
disappear my god yes what is it I think
they do it so you sign up to the account
the reddit app is annoying I'm just
gonna go ahead and say I'm sorry
redditor it is annoying why can't they
bookmark where I scrolled okay so I
don't have to scroll down every goddamn
time
keyboards like this I don't understand
the issue
there's no [ __ ] there's no space either
do you mean like when you have a remote
and you have to like go left and right
is that what's annoying cuz yes that is
annoying and is the only reason I hate
having PlayStation and Xbox accounts
because signing up and entering your
address and all that stuff it's the
worst all the urinals on campus do this
thought I had cancer for a second Jesus
that's awesome I would love to pee read
tried opening a yogurt how does this
even happen yes to suck it out rot in
hell suck their bike together with his
by accident and the response is rot in
hell this is what I mean
the mildly infuriating stuff is just
this stuff that war get started by whoa
no way that's how much paper is left in
case you never worked retail they always
have that red bit at the end of the
receipts you know it's run out oh my god
that is so much okay that's very
annoying the clear Fagor
I appreciate this one that's a good meme
I'm stuffed LM out completely demolish
these wings they are so destruction rot
in hell whoever did this whoever posted
this needs to die a painful death of
fired wings oh my god Wyatt yes
yes my our toilet see still doing this
it's 2019 why the toilet seat still you
suck so much not in Japan they don't
okay well please enlighten me we have
amazing strides in our society with
Internet technology every time pushing
new boundaries but for some reason these
sinks exists why why do we still have
medieval plumbing I don't need this
thing to either be burning hot or
freezing cold yes that is a problem for
someone who's very privileged but I
still annoying why why does it always
take so long for the sink to get hot all
right I don't want to wait like 30
seconds to just wash my hands in regular
temperature water I am an adult and I
deserve certain things this whole videos
me just seeming like it spoiled brat it
is annoying I just don't understand why
it's still a thing this has almost
five-star rated why would anyone find
this oh this one actually you can change
what when there what's the point what is
this what is wrong with sinks sinks suck
so much
oh it's traditional their sign no its
design it's garbage design that's what
it is you see one of these I leave I
lick my hands clean instead cuz that's
better than this take hot water you take
cold water and you combine it to a nice
temperature don't separate them it ain't
that hard who came up with this idea it
blows my mind
goddamn it pisses me off that's more
than mildly infuriating that's nice
enough to kill a man I hate sinks I hate
them the only thing annoying about this
failed lottery ticket it's the fact that
you posted a photo so I have to bend
mice head over and Ohio isn't real
I've said this before god damn it
genuinely pissed all of us for quality
parking oh yeah
that's room qualit leading by your
example that's where that's called
that's amazing
local dairy queen is currently sold out
of dairy sorry we can't sell any dairy
products would you like something else
butcher we're out of meat at the moment
would you like something else a knuckle
sandwich perhaps the keyboard in my
school's computer life some dweeb
obviously did this to annoy you it's not
that hard to fix them you fell for the
trap not annoyed they skipped 69 at the
menu why would you do that not epic not
epic who the hell makes zipper lubricant
that looks like four days zipper
lubricant yes
keeps my lips nice and shiny thank you
super lubricant more people part yeah
this thing that was a carb Your
Enthusiasm episode about this if you
enjoy it no yeah no one enjoys getting
my lean fury ate it sorry but if you are
part of the mildly infuriated fan club
you should definitely watch Curb Your
Enthusiasm they did a whole episode
about this and that's why that show was
so funny because Larry David actually
calls these people out it's like that
sketch where he a line cutting hey III
can't show it but you you should watch
it my read David should be the face of
this subreddit that's all I'm gonna sing
the piece are upside down Wow
wowie upside down piece my favorite food
I eat them this way through my swatter
add a fly don't ask questions
because I don't have I mean that's kind
of epic okay alright well I guess he
worked one in a million
looks like I won't be listening to my
new vinyl record I've seen this Jesus
dude still listen to it come on
so I complaining just put it in the
Cable Guy installed the cable through
our hula hoop I mean that's not too much
effort but yeah that's still annoying
yeah I guess that's the point it's mile
mile infuriating this teacher gives me
anxiety reasonable
nice Marty eight four six of his pizza
and Louise eight five six of his pizza
Marty eight more pizza than Lewis how is
that possible
Marty's pizza is bigger than Lewis pizza
that is not possible because five six is
greater than four sick so what is a more
stinky brain this neighborhood I saw on
Google Maps that hurts that physically
hurts
that is just pain to look at make it
stop oh my god it this is what I was
talking about why just don't pass and
they're free they don't honk back at me
when I'm telling you you're an idiot in
the honk language of third third third
third third don't ever speak back to me
I got swatted in order listen just so
we're clear if you're driving on a road
I understand that some cars have like a
limiter on them so they can't go past a
certain speed here's your answer
don't pass and I understand that some
cars it's illegal for them to blink out
to let people pass them because that
makes them legally viable and I
understand that you have a stinky brain
goddamn truck drivers piss me off dude
yes what is wrong with these erasers wow
thanks eraser whoa the owner of this
device turn off the dinosaur game well
some people just want to see the world
burn don't they
Jesus Christ that is absolutely horrible
hey US government can you fix the roads
you taxed me to build so I won't brick
up my car you text me annually to drive
that I paid for with the income you also
tax that I park at my home that is
highly taxed Thanks every US citizens
all my god if there was no taxes gamers
we would be living in a society you want
to sell something you want to buy
something you want to borrow something
you want to win something you want to
die I want to slice it hey hey hey did
you just die bro I need like 40% of that
true is it that high I think I heard
that it was 40% the standard inherence
tax rate it's 40 [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out shut the [ __ ] up
this thing's pisses me off so much why
do you need 40% or someone that just
died
maybe that should go to their family
Jesus Christ that is more than my limp
URI ating and I think that's enough for
me to end this episode thank you guys
for watching smash like if you did and
before this ends important check out
March it's the best way to support the
channel I appreciate it see you guys
tomorrow
well you haven't tried to Bruce emulator
at citizen e after 50 million out troops
by H don't just doubt it still relevant
just download it